[Musik]
euch sind diese Bilder sicher auch nicht
entgangen
da hat die sogenannte Kommunistische
Partei Chinas doch vor kurzem Ehren 20
nationalen Parteikongress abgehalten und
natürlich gab es die immer gleichen
Parolen vor den immer gleichen Leuten
die alle Meister im stream-chron
klatschen sind es gab aber auch etwas
das scheinbar nicht so geplant war sieht
es euch an
wie ihr sehen könnt von der hushingtauge
beten die Schlusssitzung des Kongresses
zu verlassen und mit sanftem aber
bestimmten Druck abgeführt bei hoher
handelt es sich immerhin um den
Ex-Präsidenten Chinas also Shisha banks
Vorgänger die offizielle Version lautet
hushing Tao hätte gesundheitliche
Probleme gehabt und zufälligerweise
wurde er genau in dem Moment hinaus
begleitet als alle Kamera objektive und
Augen dieser Welt auf Ski und HU
gerichtet waren das hat natürlich
Spekulation angeheizt dass dieses Szene
überhaupt kein Zufall war sondern dass
es sich um eine Medien wirksame
Demonstration einer politischen
Säuberung handelt oder pink seine
Vorgänger öffentlich demütigen wollte
kein Zweifel besteht hingegen darüber
dass dieser Parteitag der
Kommunistischen Partei eine
Machtdemonstration schießt war er hat
seine Macht massiv ausgebaut
[Musik]
denn bisher gab es in der Partei einen
ungeschriebene Regel die Amtszeit des
Präsidenten ist auf zwei mal fünf Jahre
begrenzt und pink hat nun eine dritte
Amtszeit bekommen mit anderen Worten er
wird für weitere 5 Jahre Präsident
bleiben erleben wir den mächtigsten
chinesischen Präsidenten seit der
Zeitungs doch wie hat er diese Macht für
erlangt was bedeutet das für China und
seine Menschen wie hat sich das Land
verändert und wohin geht es all diese
Fragen werden in diesem Video
beantworten und wie so oft werden wir
hierzu zunächst einen kleinen Blick in
die Geschichte des Landes werfen in der
wird zwar nicht bei Konfuzius anfangen
ihn aber wegen seiner Weisheiten
trotzdem zu Wort kommen lassen also
aufgepasst
[Musik]
das Vermächtnis des denkschaubing
hier kommt unsere erste
konstruktionsweisheit es ist nicht von
Bedeutung wie langsam du gehst zu lange
du nicht stehen bleibst das dachte sich
wohl auch den Show pink Chinas starker
Mann nach dem Tode Mause dogs mau war
der erste Präsident der Volksrepublik
China und er hat eine kommunistische
Diktatur alter Schule durchgesetzt
Ideologie Standard erster Stelle es
galten Max und Lenin statt Markt und
Wohlstand ob Menschen in dieser Diktatur
verhungerten oder Andersdenkende
massakriert wurden spielte in Maus Reich
keine Rolle die Gesinnung musste Stimmen
entsprechend schlecht wahr ist und China
wirtschaftlich bestellt nur mit
Ideologie wird eine Gesellschaft nun mal
nicht reicht siehe Nordkorea sein
Nachfolger den Shopping erkannte diese
katastrophalen Zustände und rückte etwas
ab von kommunistischer Lehre und
Führerkult als Maus sich mit Max und
Linien im Paradies des proletariatstraf
startete den Wirtschaftsprogramm der
Reform und Öffnung ein Programm was den
Grundstein für China spektakuläres
Wirtschaftswachstum der nächsten
Jahrzehnte liegen sollte aber auch in
der Politik hat etwas verändert und zwar
durchaus viel
war eine ganz auf seine Person
ausgerichtete Diktatur keiner sagte es
dem großen Führer zu widersprechen damit
machte denkshop Bing Schluss er
begrenzte zum Beispiel die Amtszeiten
Führender parteikade auf maximal zehn
Jahre außerdem wurden diese Eliten auf
der Grundlage eines verdienstssystems
befördert man spricht in diesem Fall von
einer Meritokratie die Ideologie des
Kommunismus war sicherlich tot aber
Leistung zählt jetzt auch ein beispiel
gefällig gut ihr seid der Bürgermeister
eine Stadt und wollte innerhalb der
Partei befördert werden also dann zeig
mal greifbarer Ergebnisse etwa dass du
eine gute Verwaltung geführt hast oder
die Stadt wirtschaftlich gut da steht
wenn die Ziele und Vorgaben der Partei
besser erfüllt als alle anderen wird
befördert das war den Shoppings haben
möchtest ein Sozialismus chinesischer
Prägung stark geprägt von der
konfuzianischen Ethik in der der Führer
zwar viel Macht hat aber tugendhaft sein
muss
[Musik]
ein Sozialismus mit gebissen
neretokratischen Elementen soll heißen
neben der treu zur Partei zählen auch
handfeste verdienstte der erst kürzlich
verstorbene Jungle waren die beiden
Nachfolger denks beide folgten weiter
den Weg ihres Vorgängers wir sprechen
hier von 20 Jahren in den China ganz im
Sinne den Shoppings weiter regiert wurde
man sollte sich das Ganze aber nicht als
demokratischen Aufbruch vorstellen die
vielleicht in vielen ehemal
sozialistischen Ländern Europas China
waren nach wie vor ein abgeschlossener
und autoritärer Staaten unter der
Herrschaft der Einheitspartei stand er
wurde regiert von erraten Männern in
Raten und Ausschüssen waren solche
Funktionäre erstmal in Spitzenposition
der Partei angekommen war keine von
ihnen mehr anderen Rechenschaft schuldig
aber immerhin waren diese Partei Kader
pragmatisch in ihrem Vorgehen denn sie
waren ja in einem meridokratischen
System hochgekommen und sie wechselten
nach nicht zu lange Zeit wieder aus
ihrem Amt in gewisser Weise könnte man
das damalige China als eine harte
Technokratie be
[Musik]
die chinesischen Präsidenten
nachdenkshop Ping regierten ungewöhnlich
pragmatisch zumindest ungewöhnlich für
kommunistische Herrscher als die sich
doch immer sahen sagen der Präsident
Chinas in den 1990er Jahren prägte zum
Beispiel die Theorie der drei
Vertretungen vereinfacht gesagt bedeutet
das die Kommunistische Partei vertritt
die Arbeiterklasse aber auch die
Interessen von Unternehmern und man höre
und staune sogar der Mittelschicht nach
Chance an der Reihe sein Motto war ein
wissenschaftliches Konzept der
Entwicklung des Landes hin zu einer
harmonischen Gesellschaft mit mehr
Umweltschutz sein Ziel war es die
gesellschaftliche Ungleichheit und die
Umweltverschmutzung zu verringern beides
waren Probleme die Chinas superwachstum
mit sich brachte und da heißen Marx
Engels und Lenin wirklich nicht mehr
weiter auch gut ging er technokratisch
und pragmatisch vor doch mit Shisha pink
ist alles anders geworden seine
Vorgänger waren Technologie Karten er
aber hat die Politik der Emotionen
zurückgebracht er sieht seine Herrschaft
unter einem von ihnen selbst
formulierten Motto und zwar dem
chinesischen Traum und worum dabei geht
nehmen wir nun genauer unter die Lupe
[Musik]
der chinesische Traum
Konfuzius hat gesagt du musst deinen
Kopf immer kalt dein Herz waren und
deine Hand lang halten 25 Jahrhunderte
nach Konfuzius erschienen und er setzte
den alten Ratschlag in die Tat um in der
chinesische Präsident erfüllt alle drei
Eigenschaften mit seinem kühlen Kopf
startete er gleich nach seiner Macht
Übernahme eine
antikorruptionskampagne es begann
Ermittlungen gegen rund eine Million
Mitglieder der Kommunistischen Partei
darunter auch sehr einflussreiche
Funktionäre wie Skis selbst formulierte
ermittelte man nicht nur gegen Fliegen
sondern auch gegen Tiger am Ende standen
fast 100.000 Strafe erfahren die Urteile
erreichten von Geldstrafen bis hin zu
Todesstrafen so manche gegen die
ermittelt wurde brachten sich um die
antikorruptionskampagne ging in die
Geschichtsbücher ein als groß angelegte
politische Säuberung mit der sich Ski
politischer Gegner innerhalb der Partei
entledigen wollte diese ganze
korruptionskampagne diente also vor
allem dazu tatsächlich oder potenzielle
Rivalen auszuschalten doch die
Propaganda machte aus ihm einen Helden
der korrupten funktionieren die Stirn
bietet und sie kreierte auch die
Illusion Ski habe jenes warme Herz von
den gut Funktion sprach hierzu
verkündete Ski den chinesischen Traum
und zwar auch kurz nachdem er Präsident
des Landes geworden war ganz emotional
an das Nationalgefühl der Chinesen
appellieren sollte China zu einer
Großmacht werden wohl haben und
unbesiegbar zwar vergleicht man diese
Vision schießt auch oft mit dem American
Dream so ist doch ihre Stoßrichtung
nicht annähernd zu optimistisch wie das
amerikanische Fondant die chinesische
Propaganda von Vision ihres Führer
speist sich nämlich aus einer nationalen
Schmacht fast eine
Minderwertigkeitskomplex es geht um den
Mythos des Jahrhunderts der Demütigung
mit dem Jahrhunderte Demütigung zeichnet
man die Zeit zwischen der chinesischen
Niederlage in den opiumkriegen 1860 und
der Ausrufung der Volksrepublik China
1949 in diesen Zeitraum brachte
kingdomastie zusammen einerseits
aufgrund innerer Probleme und
Wirtschaftskrisen aber auch durch Krieg
und Konflikte mit ausländischen Mächten
wie dem Vereinigten Königreich
Frankreich Russland den USA und Japan
heute baut die chinesische Propaganda
darauf wie die Kommunistische Partei das
Land angeblich gerettet hat
vor dem Jahrhunderte die Nötigung
erwirtschaftete China und ein Drittel
des weltweiten BIP 1960 waren es nur
noch vier Prozent heute sind es ca 18 %.
was China zur zweitgrößten
Volkswirtschaft der Welt macht der
chinesische heißt sein Volk also wieder
Aufstieg Chinas in der Welt und die
Propaganda gibt dir ordentlich Gas da
werden die Städte in einer Weise
geschmückt wie es schon lange nicht mehr
der Fall war ganze Straßenzüge sind voll
mit Plakette und verheißungsvollen
Parolen vom chinesischen Traum
Staatsmedien senden die frohe Botschaft
in Dauerschleife und auch in die
Freizeit der Chinesen dringen sie
vollkommen ein
[Musik]
chinesische Kinobesucher müssen sich vor
den Filmen Propaganda Clips ansehen wie
in einem totalitären Staat üblich werden
auch prominente für das Regime und seine
Propaganda eingespannt kommt euch zum
Beispiel dieser Mann bekannt vor Ort
jahain ich habe einfach
vielleicht werdet ihr zukünftig einen
Jackie Chan Film nicht mehr mit
demselben Augen sehen und ich hoffe ich
habe jetzt niemanden die Erinnerung an
einen Kindheitshelden ruiniert es bleibt
zumindest offen ob dieser prominente
freiwillig mit den Wölfen heute oder ist
aus irgendeinem Grund tun muss doch
Propaganda hat ihre Grenzen keine
Diktatur lässt sich nur mit Parolen
führen und kontrollieren es braucht auch
die lange Hand von der konfuziussprache
heute ist die Kontrolle des Internets
und des sozialen Medien ein Ort wo ist
die traumpropaganda schwer zu wirken
Unterschied ist Überwachung des
Internets oder sozialen Medien auf ihrem
Höhepunkt angelangt die aus den USA St
werden direkt blockiert wir sprechen
hier von weltweit beliebten Plattformen
wie YouTube Facebook Instagram und
Twitter und es sind nicht nur die
sozialen Netzwerke die im Fadenkreuz der
chinesischen Diktatur stehen seht her
Wikipedia ist in China in allen Sprachen
gesperrt Anonymität der Netz sowas gibt
es nicht vielleicht auch nicht den
besten aber China ist es der Staat der
die volle Kontrolle hat und Anonymität
aktiv abgeschafft hat wer in China im
Internet ist wird überwacht VPN zu
verboten und es ist egal ob man einfach
nur surft oder Block schreibt oder
soziale Medien nutzt aber auch außerhalb
des Internets herrschen Möglichkeiten zu
Kontrolle der Bevölkerung wird die
chinesische Polizei leitet ihr Programm
zur Gesichtserkennung Personen Brille
aus es verschlägt einem wahrlich die
Atem was in China mit der
Gesichtserkennung möglich ist seit drei
Jahren sind telefonnummergesellschaften
z.B gezogen die Gesichter der Bewerber
für neue Mobilfunk und Datendienste zu
kennen unterschieden werden die
Freiheiten der Menschen in China immer
weiter eingeschränkt und als Corona kam
war es die Gelegenheit für das Regime
die Fesseln noch enger so schnell wir
haben darüber schon sehr früh ein
eigenes Video gedreht dass wir euch
verlinken werden seitdem ist es jedoch
noch viel schlimmer geworden und was das
für die Zukunft nicht das bedeutet sehen
wir uns jetzt genauer an natürlich nicht
ohne den weißen Rat von Konfuzius
der Hefe der das Corona-Virus besiegt
hat
Konfuzius hat gesagt der überlegene
versteht was richtig ist der
unterliegende versteht was sich
verkaufen lässt Shisha pink ist nicht
irgendein Führer oder einfach der
nächste
Nachfolger hatte alle Spitzenposition
von ihm geerbt es Präsident der
Volksrepublik China Vorsitzender der
Kommunistischen Partei und
Oberbefehlshaber der Streitkräfte aber
vor sechs Jahren wurde ihm noch eine
Ehre zu teil die hatte er wurde zum
Hirschen oder auch hierhin da oder
Kommunistischen Partei ernannt das kann
man mit dem Kern oder der Seele der
Partei übersetzen in China ist dies die
Art zu sagen das ist kein Unterschied
mehr zwischen den Willen von Pink und
dem Willen der Kommunistischen Partei
gibt was natürlich in China
gleichbedeutend mit dem Willen des
Staates ist mit anderen Worten Ski ist
die Partei sie ist der Staat she ist
ganz China der absolutistische
Sonnenkönig Ludwig der 14 lässt grüßen
[Musik]
es geht aber in Sachen Einzigartigkeit
und Sonderstellung des großen Führers
noch weiter im allgemeinen haben dich
chinesischen Präsidenten jeweils ein
ideologisches Vermächtnis hinterlassen
das mit ihren regierungsmodus
zusammenhängt und dieses Vermächtnis
wurde dann stets in die parteistatuten
aufgenommen aber es wurde erst dann
aufgenommen sobald der Präsident nicht
mehr formell an der Macht war mit diesem
pink ist das anders seine sogenannten
pink Gedanken stehen seit 2017 längst in
den Partei stattfinden wird an den
Schulen gelernt zuweil hat sie den
Englischunterricht ersetzt es würde den
Rahmen dieses Videos sprengen diese
Ideologien aller Breite hier
darzustellen denn alle Ausführlichkeit
formuliert nennt man sie in der
kommunistischen parteiische pink
Gedanken zum Sozialismus chinesischer
Prägung in einer neuen Ära das ganze ist
natürlich voll von ideologischen schwul
ist aber die Stoßrichtung ist klar in
China herrscht schießt Ideologie und
nichts anderes und der einzige Führer
Chinas der ebenfalls seine Gedankengänge
schon zu seiner Amtszeit in den
parteistatuten lesen konnte war Mau-Mau
ist also die Vorlage für Ski in dessen
Fußstapfen möchte er treten ihn
vielleicht sogar übertreffen auf jeden
Fall sind die Ähnlichkeiten in der
Politik und im harten Durchgriff auf die
Gesellschaft frappierend
[Musik]
Ski hat die gleiche macht erlang die
nach Hause Änderung zu seiner Zeit hatte
das schlimme daran ist dass auch der
Personen gut zurückgekehrt ist der
mittlerweile bizarre Züge angenommen hat
an den Straßenrändern bringen
überlebensgroße Plakate von Ski auf den
steht ich liebe was davor sitzende liebt
ich unterstütze was der Vorsitzende Ski
unterstützt ich folge dem was der
Vorsitzende Ski anordnet niemand war bis
in der Kommunistischen Partei den hier
schön zu widersprechen das zeigte sich
auf dem letzten Partei Kongress in der
Zusammensetzung des neuen Ständigen
Ausschusses des Politbüros
früher hatten die Mitglieder des
Ausschusses Verbindungen zu den
verschiedenen Strömungen der Partei es
gab also verschiedene Meinungen
Mitglieder also Angehörige der Partei
Elite konnten eigene Standpunkte
vertreten doch das ist jetzt vorbei
dominierte die ständigen Ausschuss des
Politbüro schon seit längerem aber mit
vier neuen Personalien sieht es so aus
als würden wir Überschießen bringen und
seine Klone sprechen alle vier sind eng
gebunden einer ist seit Jahrzehnten ein
Familien Dauer des Präsidenten und die
beiden anderen waren Shisha Pfingsten
Untergebene bei seinem Aufstieg an die
Spitze der Partei von Nummer 4 sollte
man sich den Namen merken legiang er
gilt als engster Vertrauter schießt und
alles deutet darauf hin dass im März
einen neuen Job haben will der
lässt liegt ja solche chinesischer
Premierminister werden wer ist also er
war ein hochrangiger parteibeamter in
Shanghai und den vergangenen früher
etwas mehr als 2 Monate lang für die
Eindämmung des Coronavirus in der
Millionenstadt verantwortlich
wie ihr sicher bist verfolgte Ski im
Kampf gegen das Corona-Virus eine 0,-
sobald ist einen neuen positiven Befund
gab Null Code ist dabei eine totalitäre
Ideologie die nichts mit Wissenschaft
Medizin oder allgemein wohl zu tun hat
sondern nur auf den übernatürlichen
Allmachtsfantasien tyrannisch
veranlagter Menschen bedroht sie richtet
sich dabei nicht nur gegen die Menschen
sondern gegen die Gesetze der Natur
selbst und ist deswegen zum Scheitern
verurteilt aber sie war wie besessen von
diesem Thema und hat jetzt liegt Jan
belohnt weil dieser seine Buchstaben
getreu in Shanghai umgesetzt hat es hat
ihn nicht gestört dass der Lockdown
Entschiedenheit zu einem echten
wirtschaftlichen menschlichen Desaster
geführt hat mit Versorgungs Engpässen
Nahrungsmittel Knappheit und Problem
beim Zugang zur Gesundheitsversorgung
der Lockdown zog sich viel länger als
die ursprünglich geplanten 9 Tage hin
was erhebliche Auswirkungen auf die
Wirtschaft hatte und nach Modellen der
japanischen Bank haben sich die
aktuellen lockdowns sogar auf mehr als
25% des BIP negativ ausgewirkt liegen
damit über den Wert von 21% der für die
lockdowns von Shanghai im April
berechnet wurde Menschen mussten in
ihren Wohnungen hungern und es ist zwar
theoretisch vorstellbar dass es
innerhalb des Politbüros jemanden gab
der eine solche strikte Politik in Frage
gestellt hat vor allem wenn man bedenkt
wie der Rest der Welt mit kobit umgeht
aber es nützte nichts der Aufstieg von
liegt der beste Beweis dafür dass Wille
ungefiltert ausgeführt wird es scheint
dennoch einige chinesische Bürger zu
geben die den Mut haben sich den Willen
des obersten Führers zu widersetzen
Definition Polizei verhaftet einen
Brücken Demonstranten der dazu aufruft
diktatorisch zu stürzen
tausende Menschen in ganz China sind
gegen die drakonische Politik auf die
Straßen gegangen und viele forderten
nicht nur ein Ende der Schikanen sondern
auch gleich einen Regime Wechsel
Auslöser aber mindestens zehn Menschen
bei einem Drangs die aufgrund von COBIT
Absperrungen nicht schnell genug
gerettet werden konnten aber der
Hauptgrund warum die Proteste überhaupt
derart Landesrat um sich greifen konnten
lag darin dass sie am Wochenende
stattfanden und Montags ging dann auch
gleich mit dem Schichtbeginn der Polizei
Massen die Verhaftungswellen los der
totalitäre Staat Griff hat durch und
mittlerweile traut sich kaum noch jemand
zu demonstrieren und damit setzt sie
genau dieselbe Philosophie in der
breiten Bevölkerung um die es Symbol
prächtig auf den 20 Parteitag der KP
inszeniert hatte die eingangs gezeigten
Bilder haben klar den Eindruck
vermittelt wer anders tickt fliegt raus
sie hat sich auf ganze liniert
durchgesetzt zumindest in den oberen
Ränder der Partei ist nichts mehr zu
spüren von den alten Leistungs- oder
verdienstprinzip der Meritokratie alles
was jetzt noch zählt ist die Loyalität
ein wenig Zuckerbrot gibt es zur
Peitsche dennoch viel zumindest der
Präsidentin zum schulland durfte dem
Volk die frohe Botschaft überbringen
Chinas Gesundheitssystem habe den Test
von Corona nun doch überstanden was
weitere Anpassungen der staatlichen
Politik erlaube da sich das Virus
abgeschwächt habe sollen im Falle einer
Infektion nicht mehr ganze Häuserblocks
abgeriegelt sondern nur noch einzelne
infizierte isoliert werden es ist klar
worum es geht die Führung weiß dass sie
es zu weit getrieben hat und sucht eine
exit Strategie ohne Gesichtsverlust es
zeigt dass die Macht des chinesischen
Präsidenten doch noch nicht unbegrenzt
ist und er kann wohl auch froh sein dass
die Proteste nicht vor dem Partei
Kongress stattfanden
immer wieder dafür feiern dass dann ihm
in China angeblich weniger Menschen an
Corona gestorben sein als in den USA
oder Europa
[Applaus]
[Musik]
viele Experten sagen jedoch dass Co wird
in China weit schlimmere gesundheitliche
Folgen hatte als die Führung des Landes
zugibt gleichzeitig ist es nicht
gelungen die Bevölkerung ausreichend zu
immunisieren ob über Impfungen oder auf
natürlichem Weg in einer solchen
Situation kann Ski seine Politik nicht
komplett ändern das würde seine Position
Schwächen und jene Partei Mitglieder
stärken die kritisieren dass er
denksprinzip der kollektiven Führung
abgeschafft und die komplette Macht an
sich gerissen hat auch die Annahme von
Impfstoffen aus dem Ausland würde einen
erheblichen Gesichtsverlust darstellen
wie sollte ausgerechnet die Welt macht
China zu geben von Fremden Know-how
abhängig zu sein um ihre eigene
Bevölkerung zu schützen nein das Ausland
soll dann doch lieber eine ganz andere
Rolle spielen die des äußeren Sünden Box
daher haben hochrangige
Sicherheitsbeamter zur Vernichtung der
von außen eindringenden feindlichen
Kräfte aufgerufen die Sabotage betreiben
würden
bewegen durchsucht die Polizei die
Handys der Demonstranten nach Spuren
ausländischer Einflüsse wie zum Beispiel
YouTube und VPNs die ihre Ansicht nach
die corona-maßnahmen untergraben und
damit die Volksgesundheit schädigen
dabei ist klar das ist ihnen wie bei der
antikorruptionskampagne auch bei Null
Cover nur um die Ausweitung der eigenen
Macht geht nicht uns Allgemeinwohl und
schon gar nicht um Menschen Skins China
sieht immer weniger wie das China aus
das den Shopping mit einer kollektiven
Führung entworfen hat er sieht eher aus
wie das China Mause dogs mit seinem
brutalen und menschenverachten Kampagnen
wie dem großen Spruch nach vorne und der
Kulturrevolution die Dutzende von
Millionen Todesopfer forderten so weit
dass es heute hoffentlich nicht kommen
doch sie sind pink hat praktisch die
Zeit zurückgedreht er ist schon jetzt
der mächtigste Führer seit immer auf und
er kann auch schalten und halten die
Mauer der Parteitag der Kommunistischen
Partei hat gezeigt dass die Koexistenz
zwischen den verschiedenen Fraktionen
vorbei ist das alleinige Sagen hat und
nur die ja sage Wissen Position im
Machtapparat erreichen können und wie
man könnte Ski sein China auch in den
Abgrund stürzen mit einer Art
Kulturrevolution 2.0 denn keiner wird
ihm dabei widersprechen ob es soweit
kommt nun wir können es jetzt noch nicht
voraussehen aber wie wir in anderen
Videos schon über China berichtet haben
wir verlinken sie euch in der
Beschreibung steht das
landwirtschaftlich längst nicht mehr so
gut da ja sogar eine Finanzkrise könnte
dem Land der erneute Abstieg Chinas hat
vielleicht schon begonnen wenn das
System aufgebaut und etabliert hat
ignoriert die wichtigste Prämisse
Konfuzius strebt nach Harmonie und
Mittel gleich gut und Gleichgewicht ja
genau gleich Mut und Gleichgewicht nicht
gleich Schaltung denn sie ist ihr
Gegenteil genauso wie die totenstände
des lockdowns das genaue Gegenteil von
Harmonie darstellt diese kann nie
erzwungen werden sondern muss aus den
inneren der Menschen und der
Gesellschaft kommen wenn Kritik und
Unzufriedenheit nicht adressiert werden
sondern unterdrückt brodeln sie nur im
Untergrund weiter die Botschaften der
Kritiker sind dabei wissenschaftlich
unglaublich wertvoll denn sie sind
notwendig zu erreichen der politischen
Balance vielfältiger Ansichten Ski
kriegt all diese wertvoll
konfuzianischen wie demokratischen
Werkzeuge in die Tonne und schafft sich
eine riesiges Umfeld aus javagant weil
er glaubt auf diese Art seine Macht am
besten erhalten zu können doch damit
liegt er selbst in Keim für den
Niedergang nicht unbedingt seines
totalitären Systems sondern den der
Macht China's denn aufgrund des
demografischen Wandels besteht kaum die
Hoffnung dass ich chinesische Jugend
einen demokratischen Wandel herbeiführen
wird der geringe Anteil junge Menschen
an der Gesamtbevölkerung für zu einem zu
niedrigen Level von demokratischen
Enthusiasmus und die starke Alterung der
Gesellschaft für den meisten zu einem
dahinter mal indem man sich mit dem
Status quotet aber über diese
dystopische Prognose werden wir euch in
einem weiteren Video über China erzählen
vergisst also bitte nicht das Abo mit
Glöckchen um es ja nicht zu verpassen
gerade die Proteste gegen die Corona
lockdowns zeigen dass wir es mit einem
klassischen Generationenkonflikt zu tun
haben
demografische Profile Demonstranten
deutet darauf hin dass jüngere
Stadtbewohner zunehmend bereit sind in
Frage zu stellen ob es Sinn macht einen
so großen Teil der Ressourcen des Landes
für die Eindämmung eines Virus
aufzuwenden der ihrer Meinung nach keine
große Bedeutung mehr darstellt manche
von ihnen behaupten gar die einzigen
Menschen die noch an lockdowns glaubten
sein Rentnerpartei karriereisten und
andere die nicht selbst für ihren
Lebensunterhalt sorgen müssten aber was
meint ihr meine Lieben Zuschauer glaubt
ihr das bringt die Präsidentschaft
Chinas bis zum Ende seines Lebens
behalten wird wird China Unterschied
international noch mächtige oder wird
seine machtfühle dem Land eher schaden
ist isolieren und es Hintertreffen
geraten lassen wie immer sind auf eure
angeregte Diskussion im Kommentarbereich
schon hochgradig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt uns bitte ein Leid
und keines unserer Videos mehr zu
verpassen natürlich freuen uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video was und bis bald
[Musik]